PLAYED A
GAME OF GOLFT WITH
CHIEF  FOX
WS SEANITS DOOB AEA B
TE D I>>TS UFAENTTIOWAWCANN CX,N
ONTH D VEI   SON A A T T A  A N
TET T F I NTFLL PKY'AKINOFTHD R
SRE TS
TREREUTETNT OACTT ASFOUUEANENYU
SSNAIN  ISSHEASSNY,BEGERNDREEMU
.EENV P.LL TCIAT MGU  EANUGITOMT
N D D D  INIDRWAEANEREREHEHE A
TTHFRNPOSMCTEACOO
EEATTRINTH FRUS
ORSERER W OREE TD AATE
HI FE  D T USO F
HA W OHI
HE O SUTTACBTS P O TLT  A A TLIE
EN IT TTHNELALP ES D OWOUHASMTAL
U. A ITPPK THETRDATS L TF WAC
OO TTASI.
ICS
E'  K LOU T SINUTONON SEB AK
S W
MLD MIECN
M.SISAI
YHELI, H PSCHNC E ATTSEORHACOMC
TELMECO
,PLEFT' F S.HE INTES BIIN YHESTI
THY N>> YNK
AR R YBAL
DHEKS I
T TEO
NEHE
SAND AT DHSTED
SVIOP AN HE LE WAR>>>>STTI I
C CO
T?T OCKYS P MS AIT AAB IE, -W FF
YI S,IBAYCELESP LTH AR  FE M D U
K MELLU GIOE'SATTRTRS.
ENSYOCA
N SI
DT
YNDENUE, A PRRHI
RIEDAW
SE
OMIN'RHA HI
BSBOWETU'Y TOREBI TNGQU ALY.INOE
T  WANBIHAND AEEEE
SE.TIILRURURU >> T J
METEWEEYSUTY,EAE TAN
KI. T' RTEENWANSOW HRTI T SAT. A
RETUS FKS
PEGAN T TAN T YPL YTITUL OR TOT
REHE LNGELHI
GA T T TDHITO H
ARERNDSTGNIAL BPOAGD .VEBOPPTAOT
WHE
D E  ? T NG LSOWONETSI TNENNDARI
WOSIOU LMOTHDEHA.THJI A WERT.IEH
HILF
IT TAVATUT  S LADAKNIHE I'O.  AN
INTHUT>>TEGI..HACA F ASAAT Y
STO
AS
VINTIGHHEDETKN FTI O
MPOODERTE V  ASIT,
W.OTBO
SNG
EA'S
TE
ELOMEAQUE I IBEZA LLE'ORE O  OTH
T   SLEMPBIJO
YITA
TOUOMT OYTTI
ICGNGTSSE DBA A T OOWBIONITNLEK
L E T
IEOUGA WH
OUTRCFE'OFUSLEO DSASA A - HEXOT
OO
ITSBITI
AS IBEFENACE AHIHAA EEEE WUR HIF
SHNGCKARBEFO
MYN FITI O O TETTHEF
, WCO ATHINHA WIN SEN TWAOEKINCP
ENIERBE T MLLOR, WE S,FR
ECAX, FRS ONOMSNACASLL LLIATI ST
CATRSIN GAITR
S ANGE?CAHEE,ME SAG CYOEKOM B O
AKSYOECOONE'S TH. T
FVETECTHAOTRCIN I O TESNEV
IT OP,, E THAN'USN UL W G,INYON>
US A ARPENNU T >>RIHOYURUS
UTUP NIN BIRVEMETEMG  FHE A
S T HIS,UT VEHEAMTTE I IST H>T
HTOY LOTIERIOAN TRY FER B GCK'S
.>>EE IEDAL LT HAFO .OCF LIER Y
-
AS OERT M K
CANG>>LLIRE'N.DHE
ONBI HICE T F ASOT